wait say it again what Oh who do what it
may as well be called Jar Jar Binks the
movie Jesus I feel like Jar Jar Binks is
entire reputation has sort of been
repaired don't you think
no guardians to Scooby Doo keeping it
real it's Judy Blume with more dead
children how many dead children movies
have I been in oh oh oh the hunger games
haters STFU blank is cinematic nirvana
haters like it's got to be super Lincoln
super Zeeland it has a lot of haters
what is it apparently going to the
galaxy vol 1 might have had some haters
before people saw it gosh there's also
true good fun for males in the mental
age bracket of 14 to 22 which is most
males oh my yes role models I love role
models so much that movie is so so funny
yeah congratulations were stupid in
three languages
Jane Lynch with the hunt oh my god she's
so funny you know that kid in school who
would eat anything just for the fun of
grossing people out well Blanc is the
movie equivalent of that kid this is a
good review just like that right now
before Twitter
why did you the movie I am involved in
everybody should check out slither the
first movie that James and I made
together but buy a DVD of it so I get
some money oh ha ha [ __ ] ha
hey at least nobody is sliding around
freshly spewed Mahmud in this one some
low miracles people they've touched me
John well everyone has touched you Gail
you people slide around vomit yeah
person the first one she makes an angel
in angel wings in the vomit circle it's
safe to say the Oscar race ends here
if you're an easily pleased eight year
old member of the Academy that is Toby
Toby no go for the cold sore jokes and
stay for the spooning cold sore joke
savor this meeting is that slither it's
no toy story but as sequels go blank is
that pony worth climbing on again the
lego movie - OH
Pony by Ginuwine I was XXL Magic Mike
XXL you know what that refers to right
it's worth it for Magic Mike with an
apparent Toy Story - for some reason I
understand odd choice
[Music]